a president Trump on vacation in Florida
promises more bipartisanship in the new
year
the president tweeted that Republicans
and Democrats will come together on a
new plan to replace Obamacare chip Reid
is in West Palm Beach Florida near the
president's mar-a-lago resort chip good
morning good morning president Trump
played golf yesterday with Georgia
Senator David Perdue a big proponent of
repealing Obamacare of course that's
also a big priority for President Trump
next year but the numbers suggest that
could hurt many of his own supporters it
ultimately leads to the end of Obamacare
it's essentially I think Obama cares is
over the president's prediction of the
demise of Obamacare comes as about eight
point eight million Americans in 39
states signed up for coverage at
healthcare.gov this fall that's down
just four point four percent from last
year despite the Trump administration
pulling advertising and slashing the
enrollment period from 90 days to 45 the
fundamental reality on health care is
that people want health insurance CBS
News and slate political analysts
Jamelle Bouie says the big surprise is
that red states are signing up faster
than blue states both Republicans and
Democrats view health care is a top
priority for Congress and President
Trump making it a central issue in the
upcoming midterm elections the
Congressional Budget Office projects
that repealing the individual mandate
will leave about 13 million more people
without coverage by 2027 and according
to one respected analyst 62 percent of
this year's Obama care enrollees live in
states that President Trump won in 2016
I do you think this is a dangerous game
for the president now one of his single
largest drops in popularity came in
March after the congressional
Republicans began moving ahead with
Obamacare repeal in addition to his
tweet on health care the president also
sent out a tweet on the Russia
investigation in which he referred to
the FBI as tainted he also sent out a
tweet about his tax cuts predicting they
would boost jobs and the stock market
next year
bianna chip thank you